- [Voiceover] The historical
photo documentation is
obviously very interesting
for understanding
the various transitions
that the guitar took.
For conservators, those photographs
can inform our treatments.
When the museum acquired the guitar,
it was missing the triangular head stock.
And when the guitar was reassembled,
in about 1980, a facsimile was made.
That was made of a dark coardboard,
and this is the one that was displayed
with the guitar for it's entire time
that it's been at the museum.
When you actually look at
the historical photographs,
the tonality of that triangular headpiece
actually has much more in common
with the face of the guitar,
and it's not dark.
One of the main treatments done for this
exhibition was that new one was made,
much more in line with original dimensions
based on the historical photography,
the color it seems to be more accurate,
and the placement is
more consistent as well.
I think it really helps
to define this front plane
that extends from the head stock
down through the face.
The table top, which arrived at the museum
with the guitar was not
displayed with it initially,
as you can see, it's a section that's cut
directly from a pre-fabricated box,
these are the staples that would have
held the box together.
And if you can imagine that that is the
side of say the top of a box,
this would have extended out further.
This part that's lighter
was protected from the
light when the table top
was installed, and then these two holes
that are underneath are the holes that the
table top gets pinned to the wall through.
When the guitar was reassembled in 1980,
it was not surface cleaned.
Over the course of, at that point,
it's 70 year life, it had accumulated dust
and accretions from being
in Picasso's studio,
but then also being stored in a box.
The splotches and the accretions
were really distracting
to the visual understanding of the guitar,
and so the decision was
made to give the guitar
a thorough surface cleaning.
Surface cleaning paper involves using
various techniques ranging from erasers
to soft brushes, other tools.
When I was working on the guitar,
I had to build up supports for my hands
so that I could get down
into the very tight spaces
and kind of devise my own
surface cleaning tools
so that I could get to
that depth of the knack.
One of the main effects is
that the overall coloration
of the guitar is much more even.
It helped to unify the planar elements.